human brain is an incredible
supercomputer
[Music]
and they're like a
it has
100 trillion parameters
or like a if you try to count various
quantities in the brain they're like a
neuron synapses that small number of
neurons there is a lot of synapses and
it's unclear even how to map uh synapses
to uh to parameters of neural networks
but it's clear that there are many more
yeah so it might be the case that our
networks are still somewhat small
uh
it also might be the case that they are
more efficient than brain or less
efficient by some by some huge factor I
also believe that there will be like a
you know at the moment we are at the
stage that the these neural networks
they require 1000x or like a huge factor
of more data than humans do and it will
be a matter of uh
there will be algorithms that
a vastly decreased sample complexity I
believe so but that place where we are
heading today is data domains which
contains million x more data and even
though computers might be 1000 times
slower than humans in learning that's
not the problem I can for instance I
believe that it should be possible to
create super human therapists uh by uh
and and they're like even simple steps
of of doing what of doing it and you
know the the core reason is there is
just machine will be able to read way
more transcripts of therapies and then
it should be able to speak
simultaneously with many more people and
it should be possible to optimize it uh
all in parallel and well there's now
you're touching on something NDP care
about and think is way harder than we
imagined
um what's the goal of a therapist what's
the goal of therapist hmm so okay so one
goal now this is terrifying to me but
there's a lot of people that uh
contemplate suicide suffer from
depression
uh and they could significantly be
helped with therapy
and the idea that an AI algorithm might
be in charge of that
it's like a life and death task it's uh
the stakes are high
so one goal for a therapist whether
human or AI is to prevent suicide
ideation to prevent suicide how do you
achieve that
so let's see so
to be clear I don't think that the
current models are good enough for such
a tasks because it requires insane
amount of understanding empathy and the
models are far from this place but it's
but do you think that understanding
empathy that signal is in the data I
think there is some signal in the data
yes I mean there are plenty of
transcripts of conversations and it is
possible to it is possible from it to
understand personalities it is possible
from it to understand uh if conversation
is friendly uh amicable uh antagonistic
it is I believe that you know given the
fact that the models that we train now
they can uh they can have they are
chameleons that they can have any
personality they might turn out to be
better in understanding uh personality
of other people than anyone else and
they feel pathetic to be empathetic yeah
interesting uh but
I wonder if there's some level
of multiple modalities required
to be able to um be empathetic as a
human experience whether language is not
enough to understand death to understand
fear to understand
uh childhood trauma
to understand uh wit and humor required
when you're dancing with a person who
might be depressed or suffering
both humor and hope and love and all
those kinds of things so there's another
underlying question which is
self-supervised versus supervised
so can you get that
from the data by just reading a huge
number of transcripts I actually so I
think that reading huge number of
transcripts is step one it's like the
same way as you cannot learn to dance if
just from YouTube by watching it you
have to actually try it out yourself
yeah and so I think that here that's the
similar situation I also wouldn't deploy
the system in the high-stakes situations
right away but kind of see gradually
where it goes and obviously initially it
would have to go hand with hand in hand
with humans but at the moment we are in
the situation that actually
there is many more people who actually
would like to have a therapy or or speak
with with someone then there are
therapies out there okay you know I was
so so
fundamentally I was thinking what are
the things that uh can vastly increase
people well-being therapy is one of them
I think meditation is other one I guess
maybe human connection is the third one
and I guess pharmacologically it's also
possible maybe direct brain stimulation
or something like that but these are
pretty much options out there then let's
say the way I'm thinking about the AGI
Endeavor is by default that's an
Endeavor to increase amount of wealth
and I believe that we can vastly
increased amount of wealth for everyone
and simultaneously so I mean these are
like a two Endeavors that make sense to
me one is like essentially increased
amount of wealth and second one is uh
increase overall human well-being and
those are coupled together and they they
can okay I would say these are different
topics one can help another